I won't go back to the special edition
of Hannity now Hunter Biden has been
under federal investigation now for
years and as we know from the laptop
from Hell there's plenty of evidence
against him so why has he not been
charged well this week an IRS
whistleblower came forward to allege
that Hunter is getting special treatment
from the feds now the whistleblowers
attorney also says his client has
information that will contradict the
testimony of a senior official who we
now know is the attorney general Merrick
Garland and according to one report
there is growing frustration within the
FBI that Hunter Biden has not been
charged with anything despite the fact
that evidence shows that he could be hit
with at least tax evasion failure to
file his taxes lying on a gun
application form and we're also hearing
tonight that Hunter Biden's attorneys
are meeting with doj officials next week
including with the U.S attorney for
Delaware who is overseeing the tax case
but this isn't the first time that
someone in Joe Biden's orbit you know
covered for Hunter we also now know that
Secretary of State Tony winken blinken
was instrumental in crafting that famous
letter denouncing Hunter's laptop as
Russian disinformation 51 former Intel
guys right okay so apparently if your
last name is Biden you get a free pass
no matter what if your last name is
Trump anything you've ever done if you
spit on the sidewalk if you jaywalk
everything's fair game here with
reaction Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett and newly announced 2024
presidential candidate Larry Elder are
you out of your mind I mean I just I
have to ask the first question why are
you running for president who wants that
kind of scrutiny in their life
our country is in trouble and if good
people stay on the sideline just because
they're afraid of scrutiny we lose our
Republic that's why I'm asking people to
go uh to my website
elderferpresident.com and throw a little
something in the tip jar but Sean real
quickly it's got to be abundantly clear
by now O.J Simpson will find the killer
or killers of Ron and Nicole before the
hunter Biden investigation is concluded
what's outrageous about this letter is
not just that 51 people signed senior
intelligence people and that Tony
blinken LED this thing it's that they
know it was a lie because the doj had
the laptop on 2019 and they knew it was
authentic regarding the IRS
whistleblower I am shocked there aren't
more whistleblowers we didn't need it
whistleblower to know that Garrett that
Garrett Marlin was uh dragging his feet
on this kind of thing he does it want
him investigate it it's a two-tiered
system of justice it is outrageous and
that's one of the reasons I'm going to
be rolling out a plan to deal with these
soft on crime DA's like Bragg in New
York and fox and Chicago and gas going
in LA and the others that are taking
federal dollars they're not enforcing
the law all right Greg the 51 former
Intel guys they knew nothing about this
laptop they didn't know a thing right
and Tony blanken leads the way and my
question is is that legal is that
election interference in any way is
there any crime possibly associated with
this
well it it could be very very much like
the 2016 election and the actions of
Hillary Clinton look this is the second
presidential election in a row in which
Democrats aided by government officials
have perpetrated uh a dirty political
trick in order to rig the election in
2016 it was Hillary's invention of the
Russia hoax which the FBI then peddled
to the media to damage Trump now in 2020
you've got the Biden campaign that Tony
blinken convinces Mike Morrell to get 50
other intelligence officials to lie they
knew there was no intelligence
information that this was a Russian
disinformation this was a political
operation and it worked when Joe Biden
held it up in the last presidential
debate and said see look at this my
son's innocent and that influenced the
election unduly Americans were deprived
of the full amount of information they
needed and well
it made a difference could there be a
quid pro quo here in other words oh you
do this for me I'll make you a secretary
of state
oh yeah of course of course is it any
wonder that Tony blinken was was given
the uh prestigious coveted job of uh
Secretary of State uh Mike Morrell
didn't get the job he wanted which is
Cia director maybe that's why he's now
suddenly decided to come clean and
expose the corruption right Larry what
are you going to say
I was going to say in the scary thing
Greg and Sean is but for the computer
store owner making a copy out of this
thing we probably never would have known
about it because as I said earlier the
doj had this in their hands since 2019
and they did nothing with it we never
would have known about it at all talk
about election interference are you
kidding me
all right what about the IRS
whistleblower uh seeking protection Now
Greg and implicating the Attorney
General saying he may have lied under
oath to Congress how real is that charge
in your view
well this is obstruction of justice by
the Department of Justice obstruction in
the criminal code says corruptly
impeding and influencing a legal
investigation well that's what the
Whistleblower describes that two U.S
attorneys appointed by Joe Biden
answerable to Mara Garland came forward
and stopped the criminal prosecution of
Hunter Biden over his influence peddling
schemes that implicate the president of
the United States that is if it's done
for a corrupt purpose political
favoritism uh political interference
yeah that's obstruction of justice a
felony do you see this going anywhere
Larry
I I do and this is not the only
whistleblower they've been
whistleblowers within the doj within the
IRS they're going to be several of them
going forward the issue is whether or
not the non-fox media will give a rip
and the answer is they won't you cut on
CNN msnb Hee Haw as I watch often and
it's like this doesn't even happen this
is probably the most corrupt
Administration I've ever seen in my
lifetime if the the Trump family had one
fraction of this kind of
filth on them it would be non-stop on
the on the non-fox network the question
is whether or not the rest of the
country knows about it and all too sadly
the answer is they don't so favorable
treatment from Garland Greg we'll give
you the last word here and then Tony
blanken gets 51 former Intel guys
delighted the American people about the
lap help of Hunter Biden and they're all
going to get away with it they'll all
get away with it
yeah because the fix is in this is like
a rigged card game where Merrick Garland
and Joe Biden are dealing from the
bottom of the deck they're in control
you know David Weiss who wanted to file
the charges against founder Biden went
to Mira Garland and asked to have him
elevated to special counsel status to
give him Independence and autonomy which
Garland promised in his testimony what
did Garland do he said absolutely no
that tells you everything you need to
know about this all right Greg thank you
Larry we wish you the best I think
you're crazy but thank you I'm glad
you're in there for all the right
reasons we appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else